disney plus is moon night is not a bad
show it's not a terrible travesty that
ruined moon knight forever it's not a
big middle finger to the fans it's not
any of the crazy buzzwords you're
imagining but it's also very safe tame
and afraid to challenge its audience
with any subject matter that might cause
controversy or potentially make people
uncomfortable
and in a sense i felt this series was
afraid of its own source material
because moon knight comics are obscure
for that very reason he's a weird
character to wrap your head around with
a lot of stories that most superhero
books would be afraid to even touch
but the show was more concerned with
just conveying the basics to the
mainstream in the easiest way possible
while glossing over the parts that would
make it more of a standout
this is definitely the mcu-ification of
moon knight in that now he's just
another funny pg-13 superhero that saves
the world with big magic threats and has
all these shallowly defined superpowers
that allow him to stand shoulder to
shoulder with future avengers lineups
no not the west coast avengers the
avengers avengers whichever ones aren't
dead or insane currently it's not a bad
show by any means but watching it it was
very clear to me that this series wasn't
really meant to be a love letter to moon
knight or a passionate adaptation of the
source material created by fans it's a
very basic show that only wanted to
color inside the lines between making
the story rather simplistic and
toothless erasing much of what made moon
knight a unique character in service of
making him more marketable to a wider
audience
strange creative decisions for what to
change and what to keep from the books
and just overall having the same major
pacing issues as every marvel disney
plus show
i was left wanting more people who
follow my work know i'm a huge moon
knight fan i've been talking about him
cosplaying him recommending his books
for years and i really can't get enough
of the comic version of the character
because he's so different and his
stories have so much variety
but the series lacked that variety and
uniqueness
i just wasn't impressed by it in any way
and i guess the main reason for that is
because the moon night show just wasn't
made for me or really any of his
longtime fans
we're irrelevant to this whole equation
now and that's sad but it's just
something we'll have to get used to
let's start by answering the question of
how they adapt moon knight in small and
big ways but first a word from our
sponsor special thanks to today's
sponsor established titles established
titles is a project based on historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english they allow you to buy
as little as one square foot of
dedicated land so you can be an official
lord or lady what would you do with one
square foot of land plant a darn fine
tree there i love trees trees are cool
and help us breathe and stuff and you
could climb them and put a swing in them
that's right established titles plants a
tree with every order to keep the
ecosystem of scotland thriving in green
and support global afforestation efforts
with charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future your certificate
features a unique plot number with which
you can see the exact location of your
land and go visit it if you wanted to
you can go see the tree that they that's
your tree your square foot of land will
be in artery aberdeenshire scotland and
you'll be sent an official certificate
with a crest it's a great novelty gift
and with father's day coming up it'd be
neat to get your dad one you come on
your dad's a big goofy probably love
that right
i already gave one to godzilla mendoza
senior and because you're a lord or lady
you can change your name to that on
documents like credit cards or plane
tickets or dating profiles i'm sure
there's at least one guy out there named
vader who has been waiting for this
moment established titles is running a
big sale right now and if you use the
code lord mendoza you get an additional
10 percent off go to
establishedtitles.com forward slash lord
mendoza to get your gifts now
now back to the video
i'd say aesthetically everything here is
kosher get it well it seems like the
root for a lot of creative changes came
from the sentence he can't be too
similar to batman which is very
frustrating because people who've read
the character know the comparison's a
very surface level they begin and end
with he's got money a utility belt a
cape and he throws things at people that
look like his logo and he's got a fancy
aerial vehicle that's on theme all of
these are just simple superhero [ __ ]
that applies to a million other
characters
but for some reason it's become a big
problem that people think he's marvel's
direct equivalent to batman the choice
to disassociate him from even these
minor comparisons had a ripple effect
that turned the show from being a
powerless street level dark vigilante
with ambiguous elements of mysticism to
just
he's magic indiana jones and he's got a
teleporting mummy suit and he can
[ __ ] fly like superman and he's
invincible to stabbing unfortunately i
think that sucked some of what made the
character so cool away their solution to
make him less like batman and more
original was to make him more like spawn
again visually i like his costume here i
think going so heavily on the egyptian
look was a good choice for making sure
no one thinks he's a member of carl's
cuts and clips haircut group and it's a
nice change of pace from all the damn
militarized layered superhero suits
covered in stupid line details that all
serve no purpose but as you can see from
the mystical aspect of the suit they
leaned very heavily into the magic stuff
and left no room on the table for
ambiguity often in the comics the line
of konchu being a real entity or just an
abusive and controlling alter and mark
specter's system is blurred some writers
in the past have made it a little less
clear if kanchu was ever real or not and
it was fun while it lasted but this show
dropped all pretenses of that so now the
comics have to keep up
other people can just flat out see
konchu mark's costume isn't a costume
it's a magic enchanted armor that he
summons it's not entirely unfounded for
him to receive a costume from konchu
though
the fist of khanshu run from the comics
in the 80s starred with mark retiring as
moon knight and trashing his own costume
but he was led by voices in his head to
this hidden egyptian tomb where a group
of khonshu acolytes gave him a new suit
and a bunch of magic weapons that
costume had some gold bracers on the
arms and an ankh symbol on the chest
which may have confused his brand a
little it also looked stupid because he
had no gloves it was so dumb why would
you have a full body costume without
gloves that looks terrible looks wrong
but the suit didn't teleport in and out
of time and space with a magic hood that
made him fly or some [ __ ] it was still a
normal costume the quote-unquote magic
gadgets weren't infinitely spawning moon
rangs or truncheons but a golden normal
boomerang and an ankh that glows when it
senses danger which is exactly as
useless as it sounds so he ended up just
kind of hitting people with it instead
like it was a baseball bat
he did have powers in that run too he
got super strength at night because he
was empowered by the moon there's a
precedence for some of these ideas in
the books i suppose but this is a weird
place to pull from considering this run
is one of the less interesting ones and
it was cancelled and rebooted after only
six issues
with much of its contributions to the
character being ignored entirely with
the third run of the character just sort
of stopped rebooting it
it seems like they searched high and low
for anything they could use as an excuse
to drop all of the batman ask stuff and
that decision wasn't made for fans of
the character because we already know
he's not batman that's made for the
grace randolphs out there that can't
find any other way to describe him and
have accidentally made people unfamiliar
with him think he's a shameless rip-off
by using that point of reference so much
and i know this has to be where they got
these damn ideas because this run is the
first and only appearance of arthur
harrow see when i was first watching
this show i saw him and thought wait
isn't that the mad thinker from
fantastic four because i couldn't
remember the name arthur harrow i'd read
almost all of moon knight and didn't
recognize that guy at all
but apparently i did read the book he
appeared in years ago i just didn't
remember him because the character was a
forgettable throwaway he's a mad
scientist with facial paralysis that was
kidnapping people and experimenting on
them to try and fix his face
and uh
yeah he only showed up once and was
never mentioned again he had nothing to
do with egyptian mythology he wasn't a
former avatar of kanchu he had nothing
to do with ahmed or anything my god we
were editing this and i actually thought
to go back and reread the book again
just to be sure
and moon knight never actually
technically meets arthur harrow he just
sees him like on the other side of a
room and then harrow runs away and they
never say a single line of dialogue to
each other and that's it and he never
caught him and then they never met again
and that's that's the whole
villain that's him they never even met
technically
he's some way in the distance running
away and that's it
what the [ __ ] marvel studios picked such
a nobody for the villain that i even saw
articles online where they were trying
to explain who he was and they were
struggling for that appealing
side-by-side comparison so much that
they needed to use another character
entirely for the header
that's sun king this character's so
similar to sun king that i'm not sure
why they didn't just use him instead
that guy had cool scary pyro powers and
served raw so he could still do the
rival gods thing sure he's a more recent
character but he was at least a
noteworthy one that had a whole
storyline devoted to him for multiple
issues the show's version of arthur
harrow is just so completely and totally
divorced from any comic counterpart that
i don't know why they didn't just make
him an original character with a new
name i think they created some rando to
be the bad guy and just slap the name of
a character listed in the moon knight
villains wiki on him as a formality this
is how [ __ ] sony makes villains
why not just call him something else
like you did with layla
as far as villains go i think harrow
shares similarities with his namesake
and that both are bland villains that
are just utilitarian he's just there
because the show needed a villain and i
think marvel pussied out of using
bushmen because they didn't want to use
an african warlord arms dealer with a
tattoo of a skull on his face
i doubt they'll do anything with
midnight man since the actor
unfortunately passed away and disney is
becoming so allergic to recasting actors
now either the character has to be
written away forever or they'll be
resurrected via ghoulish grave robbing
cgi or ai generator performances so i
guess for season 2 or the future moon
knight movie or whatever they'll just
have to figure out how to make bushmen
disney acceptable or just use another
obscure one from one issue
you can't use randall i was also really
irritated to see that mark's best friend
and helicopter pilot jean-paul frenchy
ducamp was relegated to an easter egg i
have suspicion this is because his
character is gay and disney wanted this
show to be watched overseas so they
chose to ignore his existence the rest
of the side cast of characters got
pretty shafted too crawly has no real
plot relevance even in the scenes where
they're directly adapting the jeff
lemire run where he's really important
and marlene alronay is now
written very similarly but also a
different character entirely too somehow
they changed mark's longtime love
interest around so now her name is laila
el fayoli to give the main cast a little
more egyptian rep which wasn't a bad
idea considering how tied the character
is to egypt it is weird that everyone in
this book is white for the egyptian
themed superhero but i'm just confused
as to why they couldn't just cast this
same actress and have her character's
name be marlene l fayoli it would make
explaining moon knight's love interest
to new people less confusing well she's
the same character but her name is
different but she has the same origin
because her dad was an archaeologist
that bushman killed but she's blonde
but uh
she's not
a superhero with flying wings but she
does pretty much act the same i think
she's one of the stronger aspects of the
show and i liked how they kept her and
mark's weirdly toxic and dishonest
relationship that's always destined to
fail
she loves him but he's such a walking
disaster that it's hard to be around him
for long stretches and sometimes his
alters are easier to get along with than
he is
that's all okay they did a good job on
her i also don't mind giving her the
powers of that scarlet scarab guy from
the old invaders comics it's a deep cut
but it fits with the rest of the show i
did find this moment kind of forced and
cringey though
look there's definitely not enough
egyptian superheroes i can barely think
of any
and i think it's a great thing that
darker skinned girls with frizzy hair
can look at the tv and see a hero that
looks like them that's important
but this moment felt like they were
really trying to force that connection
instead of just letting it form
naturally with the audience you don't
need to spell it out like that by
writing it into the script let it happen
organically
imagine if captain america stopped an
ultron bot and some civilians stopped
and said are you a 35 year old virgin
superhero
well yes i am this is far from the worst
thing about the finale episode but was
one of the things that irked me i'd say
that the only character that the show
nailed top to bottom for sure was konchu
this is the perfect neutral konshu that
is versatile enough that he can do any
of the things the writers want to do
with him in the comics he's been written
as sarcastic and antagonistic
noble and kind toxic and manipulative he
can be a good guy or a straight up
villain or somewhere in the middle
this concho from the show feels like he
can be a little of all of these things
without being inconsistent if he goes
either way high marks for that i
actually thought he was the best part
and what of moon knight himself well
obviously he's a pretty complicated
character or characters
i'd say i think mark spector himself was
handled well
he's a guy internalizing a lot of guilt
trauma and suffering and he's using that
pain to fuel his anger as moon knight he
serves kanchu not because he's a zealot
but because someone has to so he treats
it like a dirty job that he's not
totally proud of but he's dedicated to
it and sometimes he can even find it fun
oscar isaac performed his ass off and
his ability to seamlessly switch from
mark to stephen mid-sentence was really
impressive
at no point in these scenes where
they're talking to each other did they
feel like the same guy he really
disappeared into both characters and i
think that casting was a great decision
and the choice to make mark steven and
jake all speak in different accents or
languages was a really great way to help
us as an audience to distinguish them
without a costume change my problems
with steven and jake however stem from
the writing
i
am
sick
i know that
i will never be cured
this is always going to be
who i am
but i can still live
i can still have a life
and i won't let you ruin that for me
anymore
please
you need me
no can't you
i am mark spector
i am stephen
grant i am jake luckly
and we are going to be okay
we are going to live with who we are
we are moon knight
and we never needed you
quiet
for the first time
in a long
long time
our mind is
quiet and i
i just let it wash over me
i let it be quiet
even though jake lockley is the
protector of the system he's very
friendly and the only altar that people
have an easy time getting along with he
hangs out with everybody people talk to
him he's he's like he's chill he's just
he's just he's a chill guy come on he'll
[ __ ] you up sometimes but mostly he's
chill potentially leaning into the evil
altar trope at this point is tired and
bordering on just being offensive given
that real people did don't always have a
green goblin in their heads i'm hoping
in future mcu appearances they won't
just make him a flat out bad guy because
that shit's tiring who could it be
interesting if the antagonist was also
the protagonist is go watch fight club
on the other hand steven grant is a calm
and civil businessman that was a
pacifist and they had to de-batman that
so now he's broke and has no money but
then they exaggerated his personality to
make him into a cartoon character he is
way over the top and it screws with the
tone of the whole show at no point in
any moon night books did i think of him
as like the comic relief that added
levity if anything that could have been
crawley's job if they included him more
i'm really [ __ ] they should have why
they'd leave out crawly he's such a good
character but steven is so silly and
wacky now and they've assigned mr knight
as his superhero identity when he
summons the magic costume instead of
using mr knight as a natural evolution
of moon knight i understand that this
was meant as a visual way of
distinguishing what mind was in charge
of the body but now people think mr
knight is a posh british deadpool and
are going to be disappointed when they
crack open the books and see he's
not that at all in fact some writers
even suggest that moon knight and mr
knight themselves are actually different
alters but the show needed to simplify
for a new audience and the result is
that mr knight is now another example of
a common trope i see in the mcu
driver
anonymized calling system leave a
message for detective flint giving this
location
drone predator mode this location
mantle
uh
listen
where you're going
tell your friends
tell everyone you meet
you tell them all
when you see me coming
run
the mcu often tries to make super
powered characters more likeable and
relatable by injecting a little bit of
jar jar binks dna into their bloodstream
so they're clumsy prone to comical
failure and nervous not necessarily
because they're new at being a superhero
and learning the ropes and it's a visual
shorthand for them being inexperienced
in some cases they've been doing this
for years and are still falling flat on
their faces simply because
it's funny
they did it with spider-man ant-man
star-lord and later on thor and as such
people really liked that version of
those characters because a character
being too competent and badass
apparently makes them unrelatable
after months of intense deliberation
among my peers in the scientific
community we've come up with a
classification for these characters to
differentiate them from their comic
counterparts in an efficient way i like
to call this type of characterization
the funny little penis man who trips on
his balls and goes boom sup penis parker
spider-man can't stop a moving vehicle
in this scene because the plot needs him
to [ __ ] up so even though we've seen him
do it before successfully he can't now
and his strength is weirdly reduced for
one scene now he's slipping and sliding
and smashing into trash cans and being a
funny little penis man tripping on his
balls
these characters are only allowed to be
badass in the moments where it serves as
an intense juxtaposition from their
previous behavior where the audience
goes oh wow look at that he finally got
something right for once as opposed to
being able to accomplish basic tasks
without the boobery buffoonery quite
frequently
look i get what they're going for seeing
our heroes mess up sometimes makes them
fallible and human they can't be 100 in
control all the time but it starts to
become frustrating as a viewer when
screwing up as their default state and
getting things right is the exception
this sort of thing needs to be used in
moderation or the character just seems
like an incompetent clown and i stop
rooting for them instead of making mr
knight tough badass or really
intimidating he too is a funny penis man
tripping on his own balls and going boom
for all but maybe one scene in the final
episode where he finally shuts the [ __ ]
up and just fights that's his big oh he
got something right for once moment
obviously i find this trope a little bit
tiring but it certainly has its audience
that audience being younger people on
social media who like to draw fan art of
the characters being cute and silly the
people who accept the wobification with
open arms because they actually love
seeing a tough superhero be a precious
little small being
then they can post compilations on
youtube of steven grant being too pure
for this world for 10 minutes and squeal
with the light as he charmingly stammers
and stumbles at every step of his
adventure i'm not in that community and
i can't really relate to their love of
that but that doesn't mean they're
invalid and that they aren't a big part
of what sells these projects the stands
pining for dopey little guys are
probably a major factor in drumming up
social media attention for these
projects and i think the showrunners and
directors are aware of this and try to
placate them a little with the slapstick
nervous wreck character as being
hilariously bad at things given that
this series put such an emphasis on this
type of humor as well as a giant silly
disney cartoon hippo designed to sell
funko pops i have further evidence that
again
i was not the target demographic for the
show kevin feige tried to make me think
i was at one point by boasting about how
this show has a bit more edge than usual
mcu products
and feature scenes of mark spector
really letting loose with the violence
and wailing on people
maybe this was true at some point in
development before like a reshoot was
added to make it more family friendly or
maybe this was just a flat out lie but
the only examples of this are moon
knight beating on an unconvincing cgi
effect mostly off-screen or a scene
where they literally do pull back from
the violence this is the exact
definition of pulling back and turning a
moment that was starting to get
interesting into another comedy beat
things like this start to make me
dislike steven as a character because
he's just making things harder by being
too silly
we're all worked up it's all just like
chill the f out this is emblematic of
the show just straying away from any and
all material that the audience might
find uncomfortable
of course
there's being raised jewish
and then there's being raised by a rabbi
my father was the kindest gentlest man
i've ever known
but there was never anything kind or
gentle in me
he was a man of peace
he hated violence
and i thought that made him weak
a weak man
serving an indifferent god
because those were our stories weren't
they
we lost our homes
our land
we were enslaved
and then escaped out into the desert and
from then
up till now
we took our licks from practically
everyone
my father taught me that it was our
perseverance that was our greatest
quality as a people
how we never gave up our faith
our laws our covenant with god
how we could laugh to keep from crying
no matter what happened to us
so when i died in salima
can you blame me for accepting konchu's
offer i put aside a god who had let
terrible things happen to his people
a god who i had never seen never heard
in favor of a god who spoke
right to me and promised
join me
be my son
and together we will get things done
action scenes are entirely off screen
any semblance of gore is out of focus
and heavily obscured and then quickly
rushed out of frame i don't i don't i
mean maybe if you're like five years old
these mummies are scary but like ugh i
don't even like the stupid cutting off a
guy's face thing from the comics that
was way over the top but this show is
just so toothless subject matter like
mark's religion are taken from the major
points of conflict of the character and
reduced to what is basically just a
quick easter egg a huge element of moon
knight is that he's one of the few
openly jewish characters in marvel
comics whose faith plays a big part in
his character and his complicated
relationship with his faith is what led
him to accepting conscious offer in the
first place his father was a rabbi that
was a victim of a hate crime from
neo-nazis in america his father being a
pacifist and turning the other cheek
from the attack was what led mark
spector to embrace a violent lifestyle
and go from underground prize fighting
to the military to being a mercenary to
being a vigilante superhero
reducing that felt cheap to me like they
included it simply because they knew
they had to not because they wanted to
explore that part of the character but
hey it's disney after all oh yeah i
forgot this is a disney universe
intergenerational trauma racism and
lapses of faith would harsh our buzz
we're just trying to make a fun
superhero show for the whole family brah
i really really worry that the miss
marvel show will heavily reduce the
muslim elements of kamala khan to
placate overseas markets and ensure that
islamophobes don't squirm while watching
it
money first art second i'm sure a lot of
miss marvel fans will feel exactly how i
feel in a few months when they realize
that show wasn't made for them either in
fact i think they already feel that way
from turning the character into green
lantern for flimsy justifications that
bracelet isn't a family heirloom from
your grandmother who wore it while
escaping bombay during the partition of
india and pakistan that's too heavy now
it's a cosmic ban from captain marvel or
something
the only moments where the show starts
to have some gumption are explaining
what continuous and sustained trauma in
mark's childhood led to him developing
altars but the abusive mother subplot is
quickly hurried off screen as fast as
possible once the information is
conveyed they literally slam the door on
it and don't come back to it
they didn't want to linger on it at all
and that creates a problem where mark
never really confronts it head on which
they show is something he's terrified of
doing
there's no conclusion to this arc
apparently there was a whole scene in
the final episode with him confronting
the memory of his mother and they cut it
to give more time to
giant monsters fighting in a laser
shooting into the sky oh god
much like the rest of these mcu disney
plus shows this suffers greatly from its
rushed six-episode run time and the
issue of marvel netflix shows where the
character loses their powers for an
introspective mid-season emotional slump
it's too short to be a solid season of
television and it's too long to be a
concise movie so now it's just
these shows always build so much to the
big finale that flaccidly just wraps
everything up in 30-ish minutes and
tells you to buy tickets to the next
movie instead of being a self-contained
story
[Music]
much like the rest of these the finale
doesn't feel like a satisfying
conclusion this epic tale of good vs
evil just quickly rushes to a halt in
fact the villain is beaten off screen
i think this may be one of the absolute
worst most baffling decisions i've ever
seen from a mainstream series the
coolest and most interesting part of the
final battle isn't shown to us in favor
of further hyping up this
plot twist of jake lockley even though
they telegraphed the [ __ ] out of the
whole show so far they needed one more
instance to spoon feed to you that
there's clearly another altar they're
not showing like we got it you showed us
already like four times
i wonder if this was the result of a
budget cut or a scheduling conflict or
what because this ruins the entire
climax of the show
our hero is at his lowest point defeated
feeling hopeless as the villain of
opposing morality and ideology stands
over him triumphant
and then he blinks in the fight's over
and it's all been resolved nice
and slow
don't tell harry
everyone along the chain of command that
thought this was a great idea needs to
be lined up and systematically kicked in
the balls this is not how you tell an
exciting conclusion for an action series
about a superhero saving the world he
saves the world off screen
and no i won't let anyone hand wave this
as a bold and unique decision
man you just it to be like every other
superhero movie they did something
special and new not having an actual
ending is totally a cool new thing this
is cinema bro i wish more movies just
told me things instead of showing me
exposition is the most natural form of
storytelling in a movie if you really
think about it
someone has to do this
the other guys
the world savers
they've got their own jobs to do
giant monster pops out of the ground in
the financial district called a
fantastic four
magneto trying to wipe out the human
race
x-men on the job
invasion of alien vessels that's what
the avengers are for
that leaves this
daredevil what's he gonna do brachiate
from hell's kitchen to spanish harlem
spidey he's got his hands full with all
the b-list super villains
so
someone has to do this
someone
has to do the fun stuff
in the grand scheme of things this
series is clearly making big strides to
push moon knight as an avengers level
hero now he's not just strong and has
gadgets he can fly regenerate from
wounds conjure weapons from thin air uh
reverse time on a galactic scale
or make giant illusions that everyone in
the world can see simultaneously and
he's got the uncanny ability to kill
people off screen for censorship
purposes
i've said before that moon knight is a
very versatile character in the comics
and his obscurity is his strength
there's not really a set status quo for
his life and things can change a lot
from one run to the next
every writer on him has free reign to do
something a little different but that's
not to say he's an inconsistent
character that has no defined tone and
personality at all
even if this run focuses on his mental
illness or this run is like an episodic
detective story or this run has about
his toxic relationships and
self-destructive tendencies they're all
still about the same guy he still feels
like the same character in different
stories sure the stories can range from
a little more lighthearted to way darker
or more introspective to more
adventurous but the basics are still
there that he's a street level hero in
new york and there is a darker tone to
his stories than most marvel characters
it seems like the series ignored some of
these basics to differentiate him from
batman and build him up to be less
street level and more of an
international hero that saves the world
instead of busting serial killers or
hunting the occasional monster at night
this has more of an indiana jones feel
and i'm not opposed to that decision but
i feel like it was made for a sketchy
reason taking moon knight out of the
street level just to have him hang out
with more mcu characters sucks because
there really isn't any street level rep
in the mcu anymore spider-man certainly
doesn't count at this point unless they
do some back pedaling i mean i'm just a
friendly neighborhood spider-man sir
[ __ ] please you've been to space the
defenders all got axed and if they do
show up it'll be for more crossovers
with the movie characters because that's
the only thing they haven't done with
them so
the best we got is just hawkeye for
street level
the street level part of marvel and dc
comics are important it adds perspective
and realism and relatability to these
fictional universes these big events in
the avengers movies affect the average
guy on the street constantly and it's
important to see that to remember what
these fantastical characters are
fighting for and what the consequences
of their actions have i really like how
daredevil's plot was set up by the first
avengers movie the criminals in hell's
kitchen used the chaos and destruction
from that battle to seize power this is
something really too small to concern
the avengers level heroes but it was
costing lives for people in the city and
was something a street level hero like
matt murdock had to clean up but as time
has gone on the street level perspective
with everyday lives has become less and
less represented in these movies and
shows
seeing moon knight ditch that in favor
of traveling around the world and having
kaiju fights is disappointing to say the
least it's implied that he's been moon
knight for a while now but all those
smaller level adventurers fighting crime
in the previous five years were reduced
to backstory and exposition instead of
just letting us see that i wish that was
what the show was about i want that i
kind of came back with a pitch that was
tailored kind of towards the stuff i
love and the stuff i grew up on which is
raiders of the lost ark it's
ghostbusters it's amblin films it's the
brendan fraser mummy movie it's things
like that there was a lot of dna in the
pitch of like let's take some of the
best visuals and ideas from the jeff
lemire run but let's sort of wedd it to
this big crazy globetrotting indiana
jones-esque adventure because that's
something that hasn't been done before
in the mcu
there's been plenty of shows that have
had sort of the street level vigilante
beating up the purse snatchers and the
drug dealers and things like that we
could have very easily made a moon night
show that was much more faithful to
those roots but i don't think kevin was
interested in that i think he was really
looking to make a moon night show that
felt unpredictable and wild and really
took the audience on a ride i think
that's why i probably got the job over
all the people i was pitching against i
think our 80s taste probably just lined
up in the right way
disassociating moon knight from being a
more down to earth hero is going to have
an effect on the comics in fact i think
it already may have the recent age of
konshu ark in the avengers books will
leave a permanent mark on the character
the ambiguity was tossed out there
entirely kanchu is definitely real other
people can absolutely see him mark his
magic and can do anything like beat up
thor and steal iron fist's powers and
use the phoenix force and then black
panther goes wow dude your op is [ __ ]
you want to join the team
i can't help but feel the timing is it a
coincidence and this book was released
just shortly before the series to get us
used to the idea of moon knight being
completely different going forward and
not different in a it's a new
interpretation by a new writer way i
mean different in the the mcu version is
now the default and all previous variety
is going away for the foreseeable future
kind of way the jed mckay run of moon
knight has been really good so far
but i fear it'll be the last one that
isn't just a big advertisement for the
movies
only time will tell the show got a lot
of things wrong made a lot of
questionable choices and is likely going
to semi-permanently alter the character
and now that he's hit the big time but
it's just close enough that i can't say
it was way off it's just well made
enough that i can't say it was a
terrible show it's just so in the middle
and it got just enough right that people
are going to get accused of being
nitpicky if they didn't think it did the
character justice as an adaptation it
felt superficial everything looks right
but nothing feels a hundred percent moon
knight is an unconventional and unique
character but this show was so
risk-averse to avoid scaring its
audience away that they made something
incredibly conventional
the showrunners made every decision to
make it easier to digest and appeal to
as many people as possible i may not
have liked it but i know plenty of
people did and this was by design i see
a lot of kids on twitter who really
liked this moon night each week my dad's
roommate would ask me what i thought of
the new episode and i just tried to not
be a complaining [ __ ] about it because
i knew he liked it so i'd just be like
yeah it's all right and he's not really
a comic book guy he didn't know a thing
about moon knight and he still liked the
show a lot and i wasn't going to be a
pretentious dick and tell him he's wrong
because again he was the target audience
not me
as much as i had my grievances about the
show warping the character being too
light and silly straying too far from
challenging topics and just generally
being really samey with the rest of the
mcu stuff
my opinion is irrelevant the people
producing this series know they've
alienated a few hardcore moon knight
fans and that's fine
because it doesn't affect their bottom
line they make their money regardless
and that's what matters most to them
it's about just
making that money
i'm screaming into the void at the end
of the day because people like the kids
on twitter making the cute fan art of
steven and mark hugging and laughing at
mr knight tripping on his balls and my
dad's roommate liking the show because
he doesn't care about comic books those
are the people that made this show
successful and they're who it was made
for
if those people liked it
then it was a big success and as much as
it sucks that i can't really enjoy it as
much as them
i can't change it i gotta just
get over it
i once really wanted this character how
to have a movie or tv show and now i
kind of regret ever thinking that
because it's going to have consequences
for the character in the comics that i
don't want to deal with
but i'll have to anyway
the moon still rises and sets regardless
of a few die hard moon knight fans
feeling let down
that's how things work now fringe
characters like this need to be molded
and warped until they're able to produce
dollars easily if they can't fit in the
formula then they need to be changed it
happened to plenty of marvel characters
in the past and it hurts every time it
happens to one of my favorite characters
with the ever expanding roster of mcu
shows and movies every year no uniquely
niche character is safe from being
turned into another safe and marketable
money machine pretty soon it'll happen
to your favorite character
and you'll just have to get over it too
hey guys our team put a lot of effort
into this video so if you want to
support us see upcoming videos a bit
early and get uh some exclusive
behind-the-scenes stuff including some
patron exclusive videos make sure to
head over to the patreon it's only one
dollar and uh you get everything for
just a dollar just one dollar i swear to
god the whole thing is all one dollar uh
special thanks to mike
for doing the voice of mark spector in a
couple of our motion comics things if
you want to see some more of those uh
that ended up getting cut for time
uh that are fully extended and whatnot
go over to patreon and we'll have a
couple of those and also
a few patron exclusive videos of like
vlogs and stuff that are coming out soon
it would be really nice thank you
i love you
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you